- Why can't we just sanction Sidney Powell
to stop her from filing
meritless lawsuits?
That's the question that I've gotten
from so many different people.
And the answer is actually yes,
generally there is a
procedure to sanction lawyers.
It's called Rule 11,
after the Federal Rules of
Civil Procedure Rule 11.
But the problem is it's cumbersome
and judges, like other lawyers,
don't like to sanction lawyers.
Why, it's the same reason that sharks
don't like to bite other
sharks, professional courtesy,
and also the fear that
if you bite someone else,
they might bite you eventually.
But as it turns out,
one defendant is willing
to you go to the mat
against Sidney Powell.
Lawyers for the city of Detroit
have filed a rule 11 motion
for sanctions against Sidney Powell
and her team of crack analogists.
It might be one step in
getting Sidney Powell
to take a step back
before she files the next
meritless elections lawsuit.
Please subscribe to the channel.
I'm gonna try this out, see
if I can do a "Daily Eagle"
every weekday, and as always,
I'll see you in court.